My wrist bones, below my thumbs, still hurt pretty bad.
Even the skin hurts.
My fingers are stiff and my thumbs lock up every morning when I wake up.
I bought a new Thumb CMC restriction split and I've been worried for one day.
So not sure how much it is helping.
I take a lot of tumouric proteolytic enzymes and even when I was taking 800 mg of ibuprofen three times a day after surgery had no effect on this.
I tried to see me detoxically and also DMSO.
Is there something I'm missing?
A supplement? Maybe a rife program while I'm watching TV or something?
Is it a lack of estrogen from the horrible blockers causing the tendonitis or the aroma taste inhibitors?
They have worn off since I have not had an injection over two months and longer and hot flashes.
So I would say they've worn off in your estrogen, your healthy estrogens are coming back in the balance.
But the pain is not diminished yet. Maybe it takes longer.
So with anything my first thing is we got to try to figure out why, right?
So why do you have this?
If it was from a restriction of estrogen.
Yeah, that's not something that I've heard of as having, you know, musculoskeletal type pain from the restriction of estrogen.
So I don't think it was from the aroma taste inhibitor.
The chemotherapy drug probably. So there's plenty of documentation that chemotherapy drugs can give you.
Hand in foot syndrome, which is really a peripheral neuropathy type situation where the chemotherapy medication damages the nerves.
So that's probably what it was.
So a neuropathy. So a neuropathy is when the a ferrid pathway of the nerve is damaged.
So a ferrid pathway of a nerve is the nerve that carries sensory input back to the brain.
What carries motor input back to the muscle is the e ferrid pathway. So that's your brain telling your muscle to contract.
But would you feel pain, numbness, tingling vibration, hot and cold?
Those are carried from the tissue site back to the brain.
So you have different receptors in your skin for those things.
You have different receptors in your joints, you have receptors in your subcutaneous fat layer.
So that when you touch a stove and you feel heat, it fires a nerve back to the brain and tells the brain in the ride a lobe that there's heat.
And then that fires the nerve to the front of the lobe telling you there's heat and then your brain processes that and fires an a ferrid, an e ferrid signal to the muscle to jerk your head away from that stove.
I don't know if that own of danger.
So what it reflexes is a reflex picks up a sensory input and it goes only back to the cord does not go back to the brain and fires back to the e ferrid pathway and jerks that their back.
So you do have certain reflexes too.
The neuropathy is when something damages the nerve.
So the most common form of neuropathy is diabetic neuropathy. So it's increased glucose levels that damage the nerves.
And it's typically going to damage when you have a chemically induced neuropathy, it's going to damage the nerves in the periphery, beating the fingers and the hands and the toes and the feet.
Because you know, how do you would you have a chemical circulate in your body and that it dissipates into the tissues.
It's going to have the most difficult time getting out of the peripheral areas because of just the location.
So that chemical is going to settle there and it could damage those nerves now because of the way your nerves are.
There are what are called small diameter afference and large diameter afference. It's the large diameter afference that carry these signals of the of paid in and tingling.
That's what's carried on the large diameter afference and they are the most susceptible to damage because of the physical attributes of the nerve sheath.
So with both therapy induced neuropathy or diabetic induced neuropathy glucose levels and being high rates high levels can damage that that large diameter afference pathway, which is going to be you're going to start to feel numbness to glean paid type things.
And what do you do? So you have to a work on trying to pull out that chemical. How do you do that? Well, that's where using the iron pro wave on your hands.
So you run the iron pro wave, putting your hands in the bucket can be helpful.
You need magnesium baths if your hands just putting your hands in an epsom salt bath in a little bucket can be helpful.
Sauna's make sure you're getting your hands in the sauna so that you're sweating through your hands can be helpful.
Live vatic drainage hold your hands above your above your head and make sure you're exercising and moving it so you move that chemistry out of there.
But if you what do you do once there's already damage to those nerve pathways. Well, then you have to stimulate those nerve pathways to heal and you might be looking at wanting to get that tool called the rebuilder.
The rebuilder is the apparatus that is was created specifically for neuropathy, it's separate from the from the true right.
It is FDA approved. It's got tons of studies on it for benefiting people with the rapidity of any kind of any type.
So it's if you look on our website, it's called the rebuilder.
It's called rebuilder 300. I'll pull up a picture of it for you. And so you can see what it looks like, but it looks like a little tens unit.
It's very different than a tens unit. It's the way it it's the way it works and the way it fires into your hands or your feet.
You also have a bucket of water, but it has to be a split buckets. You have to go to there's information on our store about the rebuilder itself. So you can look at that.
But I literally we've sold dozens and dozens and dozens of these for a decade. We sold these for a long time and people had a really good success with them.